the end of the week there's a lot of  Tina spoke for you guys so we're gonna  get right into it starting with the  question everyone is asking our Andrew  Garfield and Rita Ora and item and your  Barry Allen radar okay there's a report  that these two are new romance is  a-brewing they'll not confirm because et  has reached out to their reps and we  haven't heard back from them but the  question for you Cassie is would you  ship them I don't think so really I  don't know I mean her ex-boyfriends also  named Andrew now they do make a  good-looking couple but I just don't  know together I say why not because Rita  Ora actually recently told people that  she doesn't have a type and as her list  of exes kids show Rob Kardashian  Calvin Harris like she doesn't have a  type and I love Andrew Garfield I'm like  why not hello fun okay why not okay  season of love and giving in the  holidays it's fine and let them cop  [Music]  [Applause]